well Mexico could force Central American
migrants was waiting for asylum at the
us-mexico border to leave the area US
officials say 28 people from the caravan
of nearly 150 migrants have now been
allowed through the gate that separates
California from Mexico others are
camping just inside Mexico Mireya
Villarreal is at the border in Tijuana
Mexico with what's ahead for those who
passed the initial screening today a
good morning
well good morning meetings between the
migrants and officials with the
Immigration Department basically will be
held out of the public eye but what we
do know is the next 24 hours where the
campers here at this tent city they will
be critical and that's because the
Mexican government has asked them to
pack up all of their stuff and now head
to shelters a line of about two dozen
migrants from the caravan made their way
to the doors of the border crossing
facility Tuesday where they'll plead
their case for asylum once inside they
wait in a holding area before an initial
screening with customs officers in this
building next ibly taken to a detention
center where they'll undergo an in-depth
interview to assess the credibility of
their claims they are being persecuted
back home is there a timeframe for that
how long do they have to kind of
research that information usually
they're pretty swiftly give them this
credible fear interview in the first
week or two after they present and
sometimes they'll release them
immediately I'm on parole and other
cases of individual adults the US has
unfortunately adopted a pretty policy
default of keeping people in detention
that interview will also determine if
their cases should advance to
immigration court which can drag the
process on for several years we were
with my TFP lot and her one-year-old
daughter as they entered the border
facility on Tuesday Ian's sister chances
but in fact we asked what she thought
her chances of entry were well if we go
over there I think there's a chance the
majority of asylum claims by Central
Americans are ultimately unsuccessful
between 2012 and 2017 the denial rate
for el Salvadorans was 79 percent with
Hondurans close behind at 78% despite
the odds dozens are still waiting to
take the
chances she says even if I'm the last
I'll wait until they let us in the
Department of Homeland Security has sent
extra detention officers here to the
border to help speed off the claims
process right now we know it couldn't
have come a moment too soon because
again the Mexican government is asking
this tent city to pack up and relocate
there are a lot of sick people in this
camp right now on top of that it was
raining overnight and rain is expected
in the forecast over the next few days
so things could get worse here Gayle oh
boy that's the last thing they need
thank you very much Maria